I have a proposition for Liz but lizzo I
have a I live on 40 acres I have a whole
gym and I will work out with you for
three months and help you with your
eating and we'll get in a nutritionist
and yeah I'm here to give you a solution
you don't have to be fat you don't have
to live like this you can lose the
weight you can be healthier you can live
longer because the way you're going
You're Gonna Die Young you're gonna die
of a heart attack you're not you're
clearly not whatever food even if it's
not fast food it's really not healthy
because you're crazy obese and if you're
eating healthy and you're still obese
there's clearly a problem let's fix it
so open invite to lizzo please send her
this video and tell her she's invited to
work out with me